I won did such an abuse Oh gorgeous
I loved how she ended it I thought
Justin did gray it was really beautiful
that Selena Gomez on Sirius XM's morning
mashup on Monday appraising her ex
Justin Bieber and Ariana Grande for
their heartfelt performances at Sunday's
one love Manchester Show 24 year old
also said this about her bestie Taylor
Swift's rumour new beau Jo I'll win if
my friends are happy that makes me happy
that's all I care about so and get this
the singer got candid about hitting the
road with her man the weekend hasn't
been fun to kind of be backstage and
like watch I feel like that would be so
cool to kind of like cheers of course
yeah of course but I'm such a to me I
love what you know I love being
supportive like I love just being there
and just kind of having somebody's back
it feels good I haven't had that feeling
a while what's the difference between
being on a tour where it's your tour and
you're busy and working and where you're
just kind of watching my hair in a bun
and I get to dance all night yeah so
different Selena also swung by the Elvis
Duran and the morning show she talked 13
reasons why season 2 all the questions
that came up and all the talk about it
was all valid and I understand it but I
think with the season 2 we're gonna
actually answer a lot of those questions
and a lot of resolution with the
characters are gonna come and go into
the writers room actually the other day
and I felt like I was watching a movie
because I was I was freaking out on
where they're going and it's actually
really encouraging and empowering and so
we're gonna kind of you know take little
inspiration from the first and bring it
into the second that's the message I
I want people to know that every every
single life is valuable that their voice
can be heard and other people who are
willing to be there for them
[Music]